oh
god damn it the comment section on this
one is gonna be how
do your worst you filthy animals
now before we begin today's video let's
clear some things up we know exactly
what you're thinking and among us as cp
this sounds ridiculous why would the
foundation ever have to deal with an
anomaly relating to among us of all
things is this some kind of sick joke
dreamt up by our youtube commenters and
look we get it it's definitely one of
the more ridiculous anomalies the
foundation has had to contain at least
at face value but there are a few things
you should take into consideration
before things get too
muggas pilled around here oh god first
this is hardly the strangest anomaly
we've covered on scp explained
scp-5981 also known as nuke city
revolved around a mysterious broadcast
of a family guy episode
scp-4335 a welt in the crucible had to
deal with an entity occupying space
inside the video game minecraft but
there are countless other examples of
anomalies creeping into popular culture
mutating it and twisting it for their
own purposes what may seem silly on
paper such as the foundation having to
do research on a popular video game like
among us is all part of what the
organization does if the brave
researchers at the scp foundation
chuckled and brushed off a potential
threat just because it had to do with
something like among us the entire
population might be susceptible to a
supernatural event of unprecedented
proportions the foundation's entire veil
of secrecy could crumble all because
someone shrugged off the possibility of
allocating resources to deal with the
threat millions of civilians could
discover these games movies and shows
are all immensely popular and an anomaly
affecting a global phenomenon like among
us could spell doom for not only the
foundation but the entire world as well
if left unchecked so if you don't want
to risk termination please try to keep a
straight face as we divulge into the
weird and wacky story of scp-5167
an anomaly co-named in the foundations
database as
when the imposter is us oh god i hate my
job sometimes to begin we need to go
back
way way back centuries before among us
was even conceived as a concept before
video games had been invented and even
before electricity itself was discovered
back to an era where the gods of olympus
ruled supreme and stone marble statues
lined buildings that would serve as
timeless feats of architecture and where
a new school of thought was developing
one that focused on logic and reason
instead of superstition and hearsay
that's right we're talking about ancient
greece a society that for all of its
achievements and progression in the
fields of education cultures and logic
was still largely governed by religion
and mythology but of course as you may
come to expect when dealing with the scp
foundation there's always a little truth
in that which we cannot understand while
those who are unaware of the paranormal
might deride the greeks for being overly
focused on a pantheon of gods they
logically should have no reason to
believe those who know that anything can
happen in the world of the anomalous may
approach this topic and the subject of
religion in general in a different light
the greek gods were very real while the
myths may not be entirely true and they
may not have been literal gods there
were a group of anomalous entities who
influenced greek society performing
miraculous feats that left those who
observed them in complete wonder and
putting together cults of worship
surrounding them while most of this was
done in secret word of these beings
traveled incredibly fast in the ancient
world and they were heralded as gods
beings of divine might that could do
anything in the universe who existed
above the mortal plane and demanded
worship from their followers a glance at
greek mythology paints a picture of a
group of gods who acted more or less
like humans they fought they killed they
argued and they felt human emotions it's
likely that this characterization and
the stories emerge from how these
entities conducted themselves in
actuality there were dozens upon dozens
of entities the greeks worshiped as
divinity and while the stories portrayed
the gods as jealous vengeful beings who
constantly fought with each other it
doesn't compare to the reality of the
situation which was much more cutthroat
you see there were 12 gods of olympus
and you probably know most of them
they're remembered today for a reason
zeus athena poseidon ares the list goes
on we still remember these beings
because of the iconic stories they took
part in and how significant they were in
ancient times while for every zeus god
of lightning there were five more gods
who absolutely no one but the most
hardcore historical fanatic remember
gods of niche subjects who had small
followings who never had those
character-defining myths to flesh them
out and preserve them for all of history
to remember who would when greece fell
fade into obscurity for every zeus there
was a pythonius who was pythonius you
ask well if the guy heard you asking
that question he'd probably smite you
down before the question even left your
lips if he wasn't engaged in a hardcore
game of among us that is don't worry
we'll get there all will be
explained it's the name of the channel
after all futhonius was a god of
jealousy and envy mainly in a romantic
context do you have a crush on someone
who's already taken thonius knows all
about that do you wish you weren't
trapped in a dead-end relationship with
someone who doesn't love you thonius
understands your plight but thonius
wasn't just a reverse bizarro cupid he
was a literal personification of the
emotions of jealousy and envy themselves
no matter the context if it was petty
and greedy thonius knew it all too well
you would think that this would make
thonius a prime candidate for some
mythological drama right after all the
greek gods loved their infighting and
who better to stir up some hera said
zeus said arguments then a literal god
of envy well it didn't quite work out
that way for thonius his appearances and
myths were infrequent and today he is
nearly all but forgotten reduced to a
mere three sentences on a wikipedia page
while other figures from his era have
taken on an entirely new life in the
modern day as cultural icons like
perseus or hercules but no poor thonius
whose penchant for jealousy and envy
backfired on him and catapulted him into
obscurity why did this happen it's kind
of obvious when you think about it while
other gods granted their worshipers a
good harvest or copious amounts of wine
and partying all thonius had to offer
was well the ugly side of humanity his
worshippers were far and few between
after all no one wanted their entire
life to revolve around the jealousy of
others anthonius being a personification
of envy had an understandably difficult
time getting people to devote themselves
to him thonius was greedy and envied the
other gods so while he would accept
nothing but absolute worship from his
followers he couldn't offer much else
especially not when compared to the
bountiful boons a great god like zeus or
hera could offer and so thonius festered
an ugly god who wallowed in self-hatred
and irrelevancy constantly living in the
shadow of the pantheon that gave him
purpose and his purpose was to remain
jealous to remain envious of those who
had what he did not a god unfit to be
worshipped whose purpose was to embody
the feelings of wanting what isn't yours
thonius is both tragic and poetic and
when the greeks faded away so too did
sonius the roman empire who largely
adapted greece's pantheon of gods for
their own stories left no record of
bringing phonius into the mix for
centuries he was a god without a home
attempting to find a place in a changing
world thonius was angry jealous envious
and tired the forces of the universe
would call him forth in every new era
thrusting him back into the world and
forcing him to search for the sustenance
beings that were referred to as gods fed
off of devotion but every time thonius
would find himself walking the earth
once again he would instead discover
that there was no place for him mankind
was moving on there was less and less
room for gods with every passing year
all the popular ones had established
themselves as everlasting religious
figures at this point and they would
never fade away some took pleasure in
living among humans rising to power as
people of influence and fame others who
could not find a place in the world
would fade away never to be revived or
worshiped ever again forgotten dead gods
who the world long outgrew but thonius's
jealous spirit would never allow him to
consign himself to that fate he hated
who he was and what he stood for but
that nature brought him back so many
times before it was his jealousy of the
other gods who were somehow managing to
linger beyond their greek heyday that
caused him to persevere he needed a
purpose one last chance to be remembered
he had struggled for centuries and this
was his last ditch effort to be
remembered wherever he would wake up in
the modern era thonius would have to
make the most out of it and this is
where among us comes in in late 2020 the
scp foundation was just as captivated as
anyone else by the among us phenomenon a
game that was sweeping the globe where
players took on the roles of crewmates
on a spaceship one of which was an
imposter whose job was to secretly
murder the other players while they were
busy doing tasks that range from
scanning themselves in the med bay or
scanning key cards in the admin room the
impostor would be lurking behind every
corner sometimes in the ship's air vents
waiting for the proper moment to strike
if a dead body was found a player could
report it and the players would then
discuss which one of them they suspected
to be the imposter the game's addictive
psychological elements and accessible
rules made it a smash hit but for the
foundation they were infatuated with it
for entirely different reasons you see
when a piece of media attains the level
of fame that among us did the foundation
has to make sure to keep their eyes on
it popular media is a prime target for
anomalies the population's collective
attention on it just seems to invite the
forces of the supernatural world to warp
and distort what we know to be familiar
and this is exactly what was happening
to among us for months the foundation
was documenting cases of an entity who
appeared in games of among us and caused
havoc in the real world these cases and
their after effects were so severe that
the foundation deemed the anomaly
significant enough to get its own file
in the database designating it under the
name
scp-5167
scp-5167 would join games of among us
like any other player they would blend
in much like the imposter in the game
and play just as anyone else would it
was what happened after a player
participated in a session with scp-5167
that had the foundation investigating
every aspect of the game those who
played with
scp-5167 would find themselves stricken
by a severe case of paranoia and cap
grass delusion a psychological condition
in which a victim would come to believe
those around them had been replaced with
identical imposters the severity of this
disorder varied between individuals but
some believed the delusions to such an
extent that they lashed out at those
they believed to be impostors sometimes
resulting in a homicide naturally the
foundation put two and two together
which led back to among us after several
months of police cases relating to
completely average individuals suddenly
striking out at their loved ones
sometimes killing them and showing signs
of capgras delusion the organization
knew that something was happening on an
anomalous scale at first it was
difficult to make the connection to
among us but the foundation eventually
learned from interviews with victims and
an examination of their habits over the
past few weeks they had all played the
game and through analysis of the among
us communities various trends and habits
the foundation discovered scp-5167
an entity that was slowly gaining
notoriety within the game's community as
an almost mythological figure
scp-5167's tendency to spout long-wordy
rants at other players during the game's
emergency meeting sessions positioned
them as an inside joke for those who
encountered them needing to establish a
link between these anomalously induced
bouts of paranoia the foundation set up
a group of web crawler ais to track
among us game sessions until
scp-5167 would appear it was a long shot
but it was one of the many different
theories on why these victims were
undergoing this level of psychosis and
if it proved to be true then the
foundation would have a solid idea of
what to do next after weeks of nothing
scp-5167 was spotted in a game and the
foundation acted quickly to track down
the other players who played alongside
the entity naturally they exhibited
signs of paranoia and delusion some of
them only for weeks and others for
months that was enough evidence for the
foundation would later document several
other occurrences of games with
scp-5167 resulting in these psychiatric
conditions in other players the
foundation did what they do best and
established a series of special
containment procedures that would wipe
scp-5167 from the internet as best they
could web crawlers were trained to take
down any mentions of the entity and if a
potential sighting was discovered the
foundation would investigate any and all
players involved in the incident anyone
affected by
scp-5167 would be held under the guise
of receding medical treatment for mental
health issues and they would be
amnesticized completely you might be
thinking that the after effects of
scp-5167 are relatively tame compared to
what the foundation usually deals with
but look at it this way among us is a
game played by millions of people
if
scp-5167 affected only a fraction of
that population it would spell total
chaos for the foundation not only that
but the amount of bloodshed the entity
would cause would be nothing to scoff at
as a large amount of cases dealt with
victims outright murdering anyone they
suspected to be an imposter attempting
to track down the
scp-5167 entity were met with failure
all points of internet access that the
foundation was able to get their hands
on only led to a series of abandoned
home addresses in rural greece but over
time things started to change the
foundation began to place less of a
concern on scp-5167
it was almost as if the entity was being
forgotten
why this letter addressed to the
scp-5167 research team from the site's
director might clear some things up as
requested by head researcher abrams i've
had the site-22 analyst look into the
progress of
scp-5167's anomalous effects over the
period we've observed it and the results
are much as i expected when we first
discovered scp-5167
for the sake of argument let's say this
is when
scp-5167 first came into existence the
impact it had on its victims was severe
i don't think i have to remind you of
what billy heath did to his family's
faces but since then almost immediately
released since that first couple of
manifestations the potency of its
effects have started to decline full
detachment from reality became delusion
and delusion has now become paranoia and
the intensity of that paranoia is
lessening in each new case this is all
conjecture of course and shouldn't be
taken as gospel but based on what we've
observed of this anomaly thus far our
estimation is that
scp-5167's anomalous effects will become
inert by the end of the year whether
it'll keep popping up in these video
game matches is another story though it
was just as the director had explained
scp-5167's cases were becoming less
severe they were almost becoming
irrelevant so much so that the
foundation hypothesized that the
anomalies declining potency would lead
to its neutralization before long an
entity fading into irrelevance and
obscurity once more if you haven't
figured out yet maybe
scp-5167's username will spell it out
for you when the entity joined games of
among us it made sure that everyone knew
who it was well everyone would know who
it was if the entity had managed to
maintain any form of popularity over the
past dozen centuries or so
that's right
scp-5167 would join under the name
thonius the gods new life had thrusted
into the modern day except this time it
was inside the game of among us where it
was forced to cope with the reality that
the world seemed to be more obsessed
with a trendy game than any god or
mythological figure while inside the
game thonius was one bitter individual
during emergency meetings instead of
trying to figure out if red was suss or
not the god would just yell to players
around him one player asked thonius what
they were doing while the rest of the
crew was performing their tasks to which
sonius poetically responded where was i
i was there when the mountains were
newborn and the oceans virginal i was
there when gods walked among men and
their wisdom was cast down like sunlight
i was there when mankind was capable of
legends and now i find myself in a world
that has forgotten even the taste of
life even the very concept of life
beyond existing from one day to the next
mere continuance where are the world is
wasted away an idle play of emotions
that once rang true i am in the world
where even the gods are forgotten their
bones washed away by time a world where
man has moved on where all the legacy i
have left are three sentences on
wikipedia i thought my time had come
again i thought this could be the new me
but this is nothing let me stay dead
this time i'm tired to which the other
players responded in typical among us
fashion that thonius was suss he was
promptly voted as the imposter and
ejected from the airlock and so the
tragic tale of thonius came to a close a
tired obscure god who never had a place
in the world his presence in among us
grew less and less as the game's
popularity waned and once again he would
fade into obscurity but the nature of
thonius meant that he would in some form
return again one day
where or how
no one could say but as long as there
was a situation to reap envy from a
trend to be jealous of thonius would
remain eternally doomed to suffer the
fate of being nobody's favorite god and
frankly we can't imagine this video will
change that now go check out scp
minecraft world destroyer
scp-4335 a welt in the crucible and
scp-5254 gotta catch em all for more of
the most absurd anomalies out there